guy bedos notre invité qui a suivi tout
le journal avec nous parce qu'il
s'intéresse à l'actualité guy bedos et
20 ans d'amour et d'humour partager avec
le public que vous allez fêter avec
antenne 2 demain soir à 20h35 dans une
émission que vous allez présider que
vous allez diriger avec vos amis et vous
l'avais appelé ma plus belle histoire
d'humour c'est une référence à barbara
brûlé dans l'amour c'est un petit signe
de tendresse pour barbara
c'est à sa chanson ma plus belle
histoire d'amour car ben ammar a été la
vedette du programme du bobino où il ya
vingt ans c'est elle qui m'avait choisie
nous sommes comme partenaire dans ce
programme et voilà je suis un petit
signe va temps après elle sera dans
l'émission il ya un film elle peut pas à
venir en personne nous rejoindre parce
qu'elle aurait peut être son spectacle
au zénith mais on a retrouvé des images
très très émouvante d'elle cette année
là à bobino en tout cas j'espère que
vous êtes devant votre télévision demain
à 12h45 parce que figurez-vous que
portel 2010 barbara a trouvé un petit
peu de temps pour venir ici même en
personne comme vous dites un individu en
fort retrait mais pendant très très
heureux bien qu'ils me doivent vous avez
suivi un petit peu l'actualité il ya un
mois
j'ai le mal de mer mois rien que j'ai
d'ailleurs avaler une nota mines
voyant que paris claude là parce que je
ne pouvais plus belle comme beaucoup
comme ça j'ai des souvenirs et vous avez
vu hier monsieur labarrère le ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
en ouvrant la session extraordinaire
maintenant c'est un mot c'est un mot que
qui fait qui fait rage en ce moment dans
la classe politique a utilisé le mot de
ringard à l'endroit des dessinateurs
mais nous les acteurs on utilise depuis
longtemps
c'est un vieux mouthe un mot un peu
ringard disais maintenant un gars tu
sais enfin il revient c'est pas du tout
pas du tout c'est un instrument qu'on
utilise dans les forges à bâle et alors
quel rapport et bien aucun il eu un seul
rapport c'est dans la comédie un gars et
les mauvais
j'en connais pasqua pasqua le sénateur
masse quoi pas la musique soit mauvais
enfin bon moi je ne sais pas mon acteur
préféré qui il donne beaucoup de mal
pour ressembler à fernandez mais je suis
pas sûr que faire dans l'aisne qui
jouait surtout des rôles sympathique
aurait aimé jouer pasqua ça c'est un
point de vue je vois que vous gardez
toujours la forme depuis 20 ans quel est
le secret justement pour durer comme
vous le faite vous savez un peu de
chirurgie esthétique et puis beaucoup de
sommeil et beaucoup d'allant si non je
ne sais pas
justement c'est peut-être pour ça que
j'ai envie de fêter ses 20 ans parce que
je les ai vraiment veut pas vu passer et
est confiant je fais la même chose
depuis vingt ans tous les deux trois ans
je fais mon spectacle et je ne me sens
pas à tellement plus avancée chaque fois
eh bien il faut écrire heureusement que
mon copain dabadie est là aussi et qu'il
écrit pour moi pas réellement bon il ya
cet aspect nouveau de mon spectacle
depuis dix ans qui est bas le moment où
je vous rejoins nous autres journalistes
et où je fais le commentaire de
l'actualité à ma façon bon ça c'est
possible relativement récent mais je ne
veux pas non plus oublier que je suis
acteur on n'est pas jeune acteur est
garée au music-hall moi j'étais parti
pour jouer molière marivaux shakespeare
et puis bon il fallait que je trouve du
travail alors c'est le chômage qui vont
je sais pas aujourd'hui nous dit tout
alors vous les cancéreux voulait qu'on
se passer un petit plaisir parce que je
sais que vous serez heureux de vous
revoir dans ce film que je devrais
métier cet acteur on va voir il s'agit
de dragées au poivre sur 168 avec
quelqu'un qui est très important un
cinéma français jacques baratier en
retour avec jean-pierre maman baptisé
blippy les binômes essais mais non mais
non pas encore on pouvait jouer quelques
années on est pas ainsi à l'excès i/o
pour autre chose pour une culture pour
tous allons voyons se sert à rien de se
lamenter
tout s'écroule
je pouvais pas comprendre
j'ai tout plaqué pour le tennis
pour le tennis j'ai tout plaqué
les études
c'était en 1935
attend 36
il me restait un an pour terminer
sciences politiques
j'ai tout plaqué
alors aujourd'hui me faire part par un
joueur de 2e catégorie
car pardonnez moi mon du vieux voulait
trois ans un mur paye deux merveilleux
merveilleux joueur je suis dit oh non ça
vraiment pas si bien dit si pas une
raison pour me le reprochera à égailler
bon mais j'avais le public et le vent
contre 9 le public surtout lier entre
parenthèses j'aimerais bien vous voir
jouer dans des centaines de personnes
qui crient pas soir françois et passoire
non mais j'aimerais pas ça
pour me tuer je vous en laisse
vous avez la fraîcheur de votre âge vous
êtes gay
mais c'est que cette chapelle mais pas à
moi je ne suis pas dupe on n'apprend pas
à jouer au tennis comme ça du jour au
lendemain
très bon guy wallemme est très bien
jouer au tennis dans la vie vraiment pas
bien j'ai joué pourtant dans un autre
film de là ben ali et yves robert
l'éléphant et puis nous irons tous au
paradis mais j'ai pour les choses
vraiment les smashes sage été doublé non
mais en fait j'ai transposé ce qu'est ce
que j'ai écris c'est un de mes premiers
sketchs j'avais envie de me venger de
mes professeurs de théâtre
quoique je trouvais mauvais souvent
alors il nous donner des conseils il
nous engueuler etc mais on les a vus la
veille à la comédie française très
mauvais dans molière et on a eu tendance
à se prouver quelque fois meilleur
puisque vous un jour vous ferez comme
certains artistes du music hall où
d'autres en france vous irez et ci est
due aux français puisque c'est votre vie
aux rêves est de faire un grand rôle
dramatique c'est trop tard mais trop
tard je ne sais pas s'il quelques fois
mais non mais ces deux sont des choses
ça ne pas venir demain il faut que
quelqu'un il pince pour bien mais moi
j'aime beaucoup laventure je vais alors
le français s'est quasiment à
voyage en bateau mais on n'est pas en
solitaire lundi 20 ans de scène quel est
votre meilleur souvenir aujourd'hui
mon meilleur souvenir
au fond c c'est quand ça a commencé à
marcher très très fort très fatalement
et quand j'ai entendu des normes salle
parce que je venais du cabaret énorme ça
de music-hall hurler de rien et c'est
quand même je ne me suis pas encore bien
habitués vous souhaite encore de longues
années de succès en tout cas ainsi est
devenu en 2010 qui on vous retrouve donc
demain soir à 20h35 sur antenne 2 sont
ma plus belle histoire du mouvement
direct en direct
leurs drive eh bien on va retrouver
maintenant christian mary meinau qui
était à la bourre